[Applaudissements]
le soul et le funk gambien
voix il ne bouge pas
26 points c'est
toi tu gens qui doivent être plus
gentils de tous on va souffler dans les
naseaux
c'est la marguerite
vous avez des choux
patron anglais anglais n'ont jamais
encore que j'en ai des tonnes la
bonne journée
il va une nuit ici il ya un gars qui a
appris au téléphone un erythréen jeune
que sa femme qui avait embarqué sur un
bateau après lui était morte il a pris
si c'est vrai qu'il hurlait dans les
montagnes parce que sa femme était morte
moi je me suis sentie complètement
désemparé
temps là là on est vraiment on s'est
vraiment greffer sur d'accord avec moi
on s'est vraiment greffer sur la misère
quoi et on a vécu la misère des autres
tous les jours tous les jours tous les
jours tous les jour quotidiennement dans
nos maisons mais je trouve ça je trouve
qu'on n'est pas programmé pour ça moi
j'ai pas été fabriqué pour ça j'ai pas
été préparé à ça voilà j'ai pas été
préparés ça nous est tombé dessus
dans nuit à 3 4 5 par chambre après on a
été obligé de mettre une ou deux tentes
il était partout rinne avait partout
il faut pas mettre de limites il était
il était tous égaux ces gens là ils
étaient tous aussi aussi
perdu le long des routes j'ai pas été
forcément les chercher voilà j'ai pas
été forcément les chercher c'est vrai
que ça m'est arrivé parce qu'on disait
il ya une famille dans la plus grande
panne a dit sonia trois gosses ils sont
dans la rue à tel endroit c'est vrai que
j'étais remonté c'est vrai que je le dis
c'est interdit je les fais est d'une
certaine façon je pense que c'est parce
que j'ai fait plus mal dans la vie de
les remonter surtout quand je vois
qu'aujourd'hui ils ont le statut de
réfugiés qui vivent et qui travaille qui
coûte rien à la société qui sont au
contraire une force pour notre société
parce que ces gens là vivent c'est une
force pour nous on devrait quand même en
être un peu conscients
[Musique]
il a vu chamberlain
tu voyais pas chamberlain qui amène au
foin
moi je sais que je donne et j'ai reçu
vraiment
alors ça peut paraître complètement qq
mais au bout du jardin il ya une mare en
forme de coeur basse et les gamins
erythréens qui ont fait la mare ils ont
entendu dire j'avais envie d'une mare
ils vont creuser une mare en forme de
coeur c'est un échange eux ils ont
besoin de ça parce que eux c'est leur
façon de rendre les signes peuvent pas
rendre et ben là ils sont effectivement
dans l'assistanat life sont
effectivement dans le jura dans la nonne
égalité
chamberlain il a la tête au rôti site
déchets demi chamberlain
et du thé
[Musique]
depuis la nuit des temps les hommes se
déplacent il ya toujours une raison pour
se déplacer en fait l'objectif pour nous
ce n'est pas de faire le tour du monde
magellan l'a déjà fait en fait
nous sommes en fuite et dans cette fuite
on cherche un refuge a fait de recherche
où se poser on cherche à intégrer la
société on a aussi des rêves comme tout
autre humain
wesh pas de chez moi
je suis bien je n'aime pas encore mangé
en fait
c'est un peu
comme uri pourrait naître à nouveau en
fait
j'ai préféré chez ma vie l'adolescence
je voyais ça que c'est une partie de ma
vie
ce qu'on traverse des trucs horribles en
fait
vraiment au riz
ou tu vois des humains tu vois tu vois
des zones touchées sont tous morts mais
bon je ne peux rien faire
pleurer s'en va ça ne va pas changer la
situation tu vois c'est le putois et
cela monte ça change rien
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire il faut
essayer de digérer en fait
je dis à certaines personnes qui
s'intéressent à sa voix mon parcours tu
vois si tu te situes trouve ça
pathétique moi ça me vexe en fait parce
que c'est ça qui m'a construit en fait
c'est tout ça qui fait de moi ce que je
suis
[Musique]
c'est d'aller vers la fois simple et
compliquée et l'isoler c'est un peu un
cul-de-sac elle est entre l'italie et la
france pas vraiment française pas
vraiment italienne elle est pas très
touristique elle n'est pas très agricole
elle est un peu l est tous un peu un peu
et pas
certains se diront que c'est une valve
extraordinaire de résistants oui su
peut-être je dirais peut-être gens
sérieux
[Musique]
manier les mots
daniele morelli
il ya eu des gens qui sont arrivés ici
par là
parce qu'il ya un chemin de randonnée
nous on était en tout une dizaine en
règle générale pendant six mois et donc
c'était pas qui c'est qui fait à manger
aujourd'hui
je vais travailler donc les airs il
traîne qui me faisait pardon et et on
reste avec ton mari qu'est-ce qui fait
lui il travaille pas aujourd'hui
je comprends pas bah ouais ici en fait
ça a donné des jeunes gars sont vraiment
des super rencontre d'un érythréens qui
disait à mon ami
apprends-moi faire la vaisselle j'ai
compris qu'il fallait que je la fasse
quoi on erythrée c'est ma soeur et ma
mère l'a si je veux me mettre ils le
suivaient partout tu balaye way aux purs
montre moi parce que je sens que que ça
va être ma nouvelle vie coin
et puis le choc des cultures en disant
je vais laver ton sol en prenant son
percolateur de cafetière en jetant de
l'eau de partout
mais c'est un carrelage pour eux
un bon mètre tout est complètement ça
m'a fait bien du bien
et puis et puis il ya le principe de des
africains qui viennent à la maison et à
un bon gamin qui me dit il sont noirs et
sont gentils
ah mais non c'est plus compliqué que ça
parce que c'est des êtres humains de ya
vraiment des cons en fait aussi il
d'ailleurs des gens qui ont des
caractères de merde et des gens à qui je
peux pas m'entendre
donc à partir de là non on n'est pas sur
le complexe du bon sauvage c'est des
êtres humains
donc ça aussi ça a été
une explication à faire
c'est hyper dur quand ils partent un pas
tous il y en a été trop content qu'ils
s'en aillent ce qui était fait colo pour
ados
et puis parce que tu travaillais à ce
moment là et ça mais on a
en a pas ce que tu sais pas où ils vont
c'est parce qu'ils vont faire de leur
vie et que toi tu te dis mais merde quoi
[Musique]
au
bout
oh
[Musique]
haricots verts dans la jolie c'est le
bordel tu vois tu constates sa chambre
je suis sûr que oui moi aussi je pense
bête elle viendra
alors ça c'est quoi
haricots blancs les voilà
voilà je sais pas ce que c'est des plus
petites battue et ça c'est du pois
chiche je ne suis pas là par exemple
j'ai pu beaucoup de sucre je dois me
reste une dizaine de kyo normalement la
manip l'année gagnait encore par de
suivi lyme une voiture on va dit de ski
aux turcs h j'ai pas que les emmaüs qui
me fournissent et des associations par
exemple l'association les enfants de
coluche qui sont à bordeaux son prévoyez
un voyage regrettent ils sont passés par
ici avec deux camions ils ont déchargé
un camion ici ils sont partis avec le
deuxième en grèce c'est pas mal j'ai eu
les restos du coeur qui m'a offert six
ans aucune des rats c'est pas mal au
début je marchais dans les 15 07 200 kg
de riz 50 kg dès le 5 en titre de
l'édito sur quatorze
14 bars et quoi débarras ah oui c'était
les bars breton toile et les petits
déjeuners
au début je continuais chaque fois que
quelqu'un arrivait de marquer dans mon
cahier comme ça ça me permettait de
gérer un peu de voir un peu ce qu'ils
partiraient plus pouvoir gérer mes
commandes puis j'ai arrêté ça s'est vu à
souvenirs je me dis que si les flics
j'ai dit si ils n'ont pas besoin de
savoir qui je ravitaille je laisse
tomber je marque plus rien
noël 2016 50 grands hébergeurs saorge
sur un village de 450 habitants à
l'année
l'élan de solidarité ici à sorges il
était vraiment très bien marquer
avant dans les statuts de l'association
c'était juste d'apporter de l'aide aux
migrants maintenant c'est aux citoyens
du monde dans le besoin il ya deux
clochards à breil par exemple qui
viennent régulièrement il le remplit des
sacs c'est pas c'est pas que pour les
migrants
suis pas vraiment un militant suis pas
politique non plus dans l'histoire je
crois je suis pas insensible à la
matière non plus
si gêné de ne pas pouvoir faire plus pas
pouvoir faire mieux pour eux parce que
je me sens responsable j'utilise moi
aussi une voiture qui consomme du diesel
qui est un portable on va chercher des
terres rares chez eux pour avoir un
portable et un ordinateur c'est pas
mieux elle a même dû 3 dans la maison
non je me sens me sens responsable aussi
un peu et
désolé de ne pas pouvoir faire plus
pas pouvoir faire mieux
tiens venez ça à la poubelle
aussi je suis
[Musique]
je me suis posé la question souvent j'ai
30 migrants à la maison pendant des mois
et des mois et à paris je n'ai pas pris
les sdf qui traîne devant devant chez
moi
je me pose la question et je crois qu'on
devrait tous se la poser en fait je
crois que c'est d'abord parce que il y à
cette éternelle
je le dis comme ça je sais pas il y à
cet éternel problème entre le blanc et
le noir et que nous nous sentons en
définitive culturellement historiquement
nous nous sentons en redevances
vis-à-vis du peuple noir et ça c'est
tout notre tout notre passé colonialiste
c'est une évidence et raciste c'est une
évidence on se rachète là dessus et
ensuite il ya le fait que eux ils
passent et on sait qui passe
je suis en recherche de liberté je vais
appeler questions demandées descendre ça
me fait appeler par les free qui montre
la haine à chaque fois qu'ils me répète
dans un moyen de transport en commun
fait j'ai traqué comme du bétail fois de
plus quoi doivent toujours payer la
couleur de ma peau qd un tube la couleur
pétrole jouveau de l'offre et tu vois à
l'intérieur de moi ça coule du lot fait
bigorre
[Musique]
on
il
[Musique]
oui parce était prêtre ouvrier que j'ai
été délégué du personnel j'ai eu à
m'occuper des gardiens concierge aussi
au niveau syndical
regardez monsieur keita qui arrive
pouvait passer il n'y a pas de problème
si vous voulez vous arrêter même c'est
comme parler justement de tous les
africains il doit mener tout cela on ne
s'y attendait
lui travaille à l'hôpital lasalle hasard
il ya eu de tout qui sont passés des
nigériens
mais c'était des moments de
ben c'était ça changeait de la routine
il ya eu deux camerounais j'ai un pli
comme ça aussi moche que nicole cameroun
c'était une pièce qu'on a une
démocrature a fait un peu régime peu à
poigne d'accord mais enfin mais c'est
chaud là bas rhin come on to me disais
africain
quand j'étais là-bas en afrique mois les
montagnes me manquez pas ce que c'était
tout plat fin de la peine au beau soleil
à s'était alors eux qui viennent qui
sont pas habitués à ça il ya peut-être
la nostalgie ou quoi le souvenir de leur
pays et puis de voir ce qu ils bavent ce
moment moi ils ont dormi à katie sont
arrivés qui somme il avait besoin de
récupérer
alors ce jour là pour la fête de
saint-pierre d'alcantara il y à la messe
on était chez françoise cotta pour cette
messe donc c'était le
27 octobre
et je venais d'apprendre que sept
érythréens là
on avait prévenu le soir 11 heures du
soir que sa femme était décédée dans la
méditerranée
alors on m'a pris à ce moment là en
train de dessiner mais que lui dire poc
pour le réponse le réconforter pour je
peux pas lui raconter des salades quand
même
dans les années 1800 et 17/100 même
avant que quand on a fait des comptoirs
là bas en afrique
on était des réfugiés économiques ou
quoi on allait les pompes et
il peut aussi installer on leur a pas
demandé la permission de venir là bas on
est allé avec les canonnières avec les
on a même diviser les peuples là bas
pour faire des troupes supplétives des
ascaride et des méharis des trucs
et alors et maintenant on voudrait faire
la fine bouche parce qu'il faudrait pas
parce que il arrive les bains les mêmes
vide alors que nous on est allé avec des
armes épée avec un autre nos provisions
un bien souvent parce qu'on s'habitue et
pas trop à la nourriture africaine
alors qu'est ce que c'est moi je crois
que l'histoire elle elle est passée à
l'envers autrefois 17e 18e 19e siècle on
est allé porter la civilisation rame sur
jules ferry cause était intelligent
d'aller apporter la civilisation à ces
gens qui avaient une civilisation
[Musique]
non
là tout ce qu'on voit on voit que de la
france bich dès que tu passes la crète
derrière c'est l'italie
ouais je suis la dernière maison avant
la frontière italienne mais il ya 11
heures de marche à pied donc ça laisse
un peu de marge
ma famille est là pendant la guerre elle
a été déportée parce qu'en fait c'était
une ligne de front donc là tu vois
l'italie derrière sur sow spel c'était
la ligne de front française et entre on
m'en donnait en 43 45 ça a été le
espèce de couloir no man's land et donc
ça or j'étais dans ce couloir et ma
famille étaient déportés en italie et
donc moi l'idée de la solidarité gelé
tout connement sur un truc rien du tout
parce que ma grand-mère me disait quand
on a marché de saorge ans à turin à pied
quand on a traversé certains villages du
piémont il ya des gens qui ont ouvert
leurs portes et qui ont donné quelque
chose et tu te dis bah et moi j'essaie
d'idées de la solidarité s'il faut il
n'avait qu'une qui a ouvert la porte
dans c'est rien c'est pas plus et donc
au niveau des mois j'ai l'idée que
dans la vallée derrière c'était
des solitaires
voilà
ça fait 40 ans que je fais de
l'associatif je me bagarre dans la
plaine de domaine donc mais on voulait
bien que je sois gauchiste mais que je
défende le train ça va que je défends de
la poste les écoles ça pose pas problème
mais défendre du black s'est pas c'est
ça le je crois le problème c'est c'est
drôle ça alors qu'ils en ont jamais vu
attendre qu'ils ont jamais été envahie
par par des noirs
donc café pour tout le monde ou thé
vert thé café
nous samoussas il est tout à fait en
règle et est pris en charge tout à fait
correctement c'est vraiment quelque
chose qui est je pense il ne réussit
même si on n'est pas en accord complet
avec ce que fait le département par
ailleurs sur le cas de moussa
précisément et peut-être quelques autres
cas là il ya rien à dire comment tu as
vu un peu la façon dont les gens ont
réagi si le père réside dans le fait
qu'après parce que moi
je t'en prie vas-y vas-y s'il te plaît
parce que j'ai pas envie je dois du
voile la face à des françaises en 2019
et il lui piquer ses toujours sur l'idée
que ça risque de lui nuire
[Musique]
il ya les vieux qui disent comme moi il
y bien et nous on plutôt travailler les
consciences à ouvrir le débat des
discussions avec des gens même si c'est
un voisin qu'on va que notre discours il
est pendu à paris on en a rien à
mais nous c'est dans la vallée il faut
qu'on sache pourquoi on fait ça pourquoi
comment on est perçu comment on peut
faire changer les mentalités
l'important c'est la durée c'est pas le
sait pas
l'éclair c'est bien un moment mais pour
que ça dure
[Musique]
on y vient pousser à côté là où il ya
mon petit scooter haut en bas de mon
jardin ici j'aime pas pour nous on n'est
pas habitué à ça je suis désolé soit
habitué à pisser contre les arbres en
plein jour tu vas dans l'atoll
cheat aliens tu te fais les infos je
travaille je demande est rien ils ont
tous et nous on n'a rien il ya trop
d'histoires je suis désolé s'est scindé
racisme en italie c'est en italien il
est comme ça et ils sont comme ça
ils veulent pas mal gérée maccheroni l
espagne et qui parce que c'est pas dans
leurs eaux mais cette affaire tu te
mange même la boîte
mais moi leur âge kg s'est par contre
lui personnellement eux qui ne font
chier parce qu'ils sont là ils donnent
une rigole et aux bains à un moment les
robinets que le fermer un peu plus mais
moi je suis fâché avec une autre étape
dans le talent d'un fou qui jusqu'à
maintenant
le gros de la poule
invaincu dans ce travail
non vous recommande
certains tentent le passage plusieurs
fois
mais dans ses tentatives il y à des
personnes qui laissent leur vie et je
voudrais connaît un petit moment une
pensée pour ces personnes on va donc
prononcer les noms des personnes
décédées pas loin de la frontière
le 22 novembre 2016 halim onu kingsley
nigérian de 23 ans se noie emporté par
la royne ya un jeune homme dans
l'afrique un autre 20 et 25 ans et
percuté par un train dans le tunnel de
documents le 19 mai 2010 7,1 hors malien
de 30 ans et être occultés dans le
compartiment technique du travail venant
de vintimille
23 mai 2010 est un homme sénégalais et
retrouver de la même façon
à
m
en faisant cette marche vous allez
emprunter le chemin pour en emprunter
beaucoup de migrants pour se rendre dans
la roya française puis rejoindre la
france vous allez traverser la frontière
à pied vous n'aurez aucun problème
vous avez compris pourquoi c'est
simplement une question de couleur
à
j'ai pas n'en a pas fait de comptage
nous avons demandé à l'afrique en bas on
leur demandait ça
dans un chemin de jésus
[Musique]
et on la détruit
la roya solidaire la roya terre
d'accueil c'est vraiment un cliché je
suis désolé je sais que ça plaît
beaucoup ça mais
non c'est beaucoup plus complexe que ça
il ya aussi tous ses réflexes de peur
les gens ici qui
sont pas content né sont pas contents
quand on voit la roya comme ça qu'elles
soient célèbres avec ces valeurs là mais
c'est pas grave c'est pas grave
[Musique]
voilà
au début il y avait des gens qui étaient
vraiment sur
l'humanitaire bon ce débat entre
politique ou humanitaire on l'a eu
plusieurs reprises certaines personnes
souhaitant au début qu'on fasse que
l'humanitaire petit à petit d'autres
personnes qui souhaitaient qu'on fasse
que du politique que du politique ça
voulait dire ça veut dire quoi je ne
sais pas ça voulait dire
moi j'en sais rien moi arrêtez d'acheter
des couvertures arrêter d'acheter à
manger but est de faire à manger et ne
faire que des communiqués des soirées
pas bon bref en tout cas au final on a
un positionnement a été arrêté et est
arrêté sur ces les deux c'est assez
simple il faut les deux
[Musique]
ça met une échelle de priorités et de
dans la vie
qui moi m'a été précieuse qu'il est
toujours en fait c'est
super quand tu as en face de toi enfin
au côté de toi des gens qui n'ont rien
et qui sont
à qui on dénie toute dignité et tout
droit en fait quelque part en ton nom
parce que c'est
l'europe et la france qui font ça
mais je sais bien que je vais pas
pouvoir aimer qu'ibra aller contre ce
que fait le gouvernement français mais
je fais ce que tout ce que je peux
ça m'a rendu en fait moi plus forte et
plus convaincu
oui
[Musique]
javier depuis
la marque
pas
mal
les gentils des descentes de l'émigrant
créer un problème parce que
d'autres personnes me disent on en a
marre on nous parle que de ça et ils
sont prêts à voter extrême droite et il
ya déjà sept pays en europe
qui votent à droite et il faudrait pas
que ça arrive chez nous je fais 37 ans
de mandat électoral sur la commune et
aux dernières élections j'ai plus voulu
me représenter le fmi fait combien breil
au delà il a fait 47 son sens des mois
il a été il commence à bien vos essais
et je crois que si qui avait pas eu
toute cette publicité autour des
migrants il n'y aurait pas eu ce
résultat je pense ça vient de la
publicité et les gens ça les énerve
qu'on parle toujours de ça et
parce que si des migrants vous en voyez
très peu
alors j'ai reçu un message de
remerciement
on a présenté les gens aient besoin le
valais comme étant des yankees et des
volontiers des migrants c'est vrai pita
chacun qui se trouvait en face d'un
migrant à une occasion de l'aider sur
des choses parfois dérisoires c'est
devenu une bouteille d'eau avec un qui
passe c'est souvent des choses aussi
simples que ça arrivait bien sûr ça
m'est arrivé ça m'est arrivé comme tout
le monde je pense que tout le monde est
alors stoppé de vue politique j'ai vu
des situations extraordinaires gens qui
ne pouvaient crier autant qu'il voulait
contre des migrants quand vous avez une
famille en face de vous bien sûr que
vous avez l'aider bien sûr
moi je représente les commerçants de
braye fontan saorge mais c'est encore
moi qui cherche à avoir un peu leur leur
expression les gens qui sont là et qui
voit l'évolution de la vallée
il n'arrive pas à faire la dissociation
entre ce qui est la mutation économique
générale on ressent ici parce que on a
des petits commerces qui disparaissent
ils sont là effectivement ils
disparaissent mais c'est parce que les
populations change aussi je ne pense pas
que les questions migratoires et changer
grand chose
ya un truc que je comprends pas c'est
des gars qui ont entre 18 et 30 ans
c'est tous des jeunes tu pourrais être
dans leur pays ont dit adil politique a
dit ceci je suis pas d'accord moi je
regrette mon pays aurait des problèmes
je resterai ici pour le combattre un
pour combattre le fléau j'ai rêvé par an
avant tout parce qu'il a la bonne heure
par heure modem tour
je fais pas moi
tout le monde sait que je suis le front
national en national je peux m'en que c
est au début que l'on ne savait pas on
disait pas bonjour mais maintenant et
les mains stands ce qui me connaissent
mieux
que les gens du village ici commence à
s'énerver un croyez moi ils commencent à
s'énerver là et là on arrive sur les
beaux jours savard a trouvé ça va
appliquer et moi je que je souhaite
qu'un jour qui ait pas de conflit entre
des villageois et des biens
il parle mais se cache puis la cuisse
pas c'est ça le groupe les eaux de la
vallée dans les bars et vous faites tous
mais quand il pourrait inscrire qu'un
seul
elle
une fois par exemple ici à bord et ya un
mec qui est sorti de chez lui en fait il
a craché 4 que je vous vois je les
regardais en fait il était bien costaud
mais quand je les regarde et j'ai vu un
truc des minuscules en fait
je n'ai senti tout toi je les ai vus
tout petit a fait je me suis dit
sûrement ça c'est un enfant qui n'est
pas signé beaucoup de trucs tu vois que
tu en surnombre qui en famille la dgos
tu vois ici comporte une phase je veux
pas le suivre dans sa bêtise en fait
j'ai gardé le silence
soit pas ceci il faut que je me repose
tu voi le mec qui est déjà tendue en
fait si je repars et qu'il ne reçoit pas
bien mon message je vois ça crée une
tension et ça ça peut mal fini tu vois
je me suis dit peut-être il ira boire un
café savoir les détails
[Musique]
de ma
part et je reste que clint du reste que
trois formules que je pense que j'ai
reconnue des grandes voix qui manquera
c'est moi j'ai pas d'éducation dressé
comme un animal tout comme un lion frais
voilà la mama diop deux mois celui qui a
lâché craché
de ma bouche de mona
la peur de la justice c'est ça
à
ouais ouais
un joli
c'est un peu devant le panneau quand on
est parfait pour rien pour aujourd'hui à
1 096
merci à tout le monde surtout merci
nous on essaye d'alerter les pouvoirs
publics en disant bon qu'est-ce qu'on
fait des demandeurs d'asile des mineurs
isolés comment on peut faire et ces
personnes monsieur préfet web sous
préfet vous pouvez pas monter on peut
pas discutable par une solution
personnes la solution c'est de mettre
cinquante gendarmes mobiles autour de
mon domicile pendant plus de quatre mois
donc avec des flashs lumineux la nuit
pour surveiller nouveau nos allées et
venues six perquisitions dont 4 abusive
neuf gardes à vue à ce harcèlement
[Applaudissements]
il ya quand même un maximum de 150
personnes ici et à gérer ce comme
compliquée quoi cette personne se
fatiguer ces personnes qui ont peur
qu'ils ont plus d'argent qu'ils n'ont
pas de matériaux dont qui sont dans la
misère la plus totale quoi et c'est vrai
que d'un seul et ça peut s'enflammer
c'est sur quoi s'est toujours bien passé
alors papa de service d'ordre on n'a pas
ça marche ça marche assez bien
mais si on n'a pas de subventions on est
complètement indépendant financièrement
et on répare les carences de l'état et
les failles de l'état son point de vue
humanitaire son pôle juridique et en
plus on dénonce et ça par contre il
n'aime pas du tout qu'on l'a on voit
autour de la ferme et dans la vallée de
la roya il ya environ 500 gendarmes
mobiles baffe douaniers des sentinelles
qui courent après les noirs dans la
forêt etc qu'est ce qui se passe là
c'est de la communication c'est de dire
attention et touré roux sami dangereux
et cetera ma chasse un anarchiste ultra
gauche c'est en fait ils communiquent
donc en fait ce qu'il faut faire c'est
nous aussi communiquer communiquer par
là la voisine au cousin à la nièce à nos
enfants toutes ces armes là tous ces
outils la télévision média radio etc il
faut les reprendre possession
que trop mignon
bien plus large et reçoit tu fais un
opposant un système d'état un système
d'état en fait qui qui qui incrimine qui
poursuivent qui maltraitent une partie
d'une population parce qu'elle est lé lé
pauvre parce qu'elle est petite pas ce
qu'elle est sans défense parce que c'est
elle a pas les moyens de se battre
c'est pour ça que je me bats je ne va
pas pour des noirs qui migrent je
m'ajuste parce qu'il ya des gens en fait
qu'ils sont qui ne sont pas respectés
par notre état notre gouvernement se
consacre aux juges me battre
[Musique]
ouais il a soufflé le vent de la liberté
ouais fois la vie c'est ça deux fois
souffle de vent favorable
des trucs qu'on ne peut pas expliquer en
fait il ça arrive je veux c'est jouer
tant pour être le moment à tout le match
pour monter descendre une teuf
[Musique]
tu as m à saint dalmas
qui fait partie de ma famille me suis
dit tu vois dans un style temps en temps
je fais ces deux gosses il ne manquerait
en fait je fasse le temps avec eux je
suis bien et ses gosses
tu vois c'est des mecs qui
il est tellement l'ennemi comme il reste
un monument en fait il ne médiatise
famille il est tout le temps
[Musique]
tout rappelle jean bie commenté réguler
si toi
[Musique]
je me souviens plus pourquoi tu es
arrivé chez moi si ce voyage mais
ouais c'est ça en fait j'ai oublié c'est
mon fils en fait
tout de suite beaucoup beaucoup
d'affection pour lui je sais pas il ya
ce qui dit
son calme
et puis là je crois qu'on était de toute
façon sur la même longueur d'onde dès le
départ son il est conscient des
problèmes que ce qu'il soit politique
économique ou écologique dans le monde
il en est très conscient son
positionnement il est aussi vraiment
basée sur la non violence sur l'amour
sur des choses simples comme ça donc on
a c'était tellement facile dès le départ
quoi et puis puis maintenant on découvre
enfin moi je découvre je savais pas mais
son côté clown qui était un petit peu
oblitéré au départ là
mais des fois on a été jusqu'à l'été et
jusqu'à 10 personnes en même temps ici
moi j'ai pleuré je sais pas combien de
fois sur les quais de gare avec un mec
dans les bras que je connaissais depuis
dix jours quoi dire quoi mais comme un
bébé comme c'était mon frère qui partait
on est en face d'un problème humain là
et bien sûr ce problème humain il a des
causes économiques politiques etc mais
qui sait même plus profond que ça parce
que c'est c'est notre mode de vie à tout
ce système capitaliste ce qu'il a généré
comment il fonctionne et il a engendré
ça alors soit on décide de mettre tout
ça en même sac et on fait un grand
combat
plus ou moins leurs six ans contre les
pouvoirs politiques et les soi disant
responsables de ça mais du coup on n'est
plus le projet ça devient d'essayer de
retourner une civilisation qui part en
couille ça devient plus d'aider des mecs
qui sont dans la rue c'est une autre
question ça pour moi pour nous et cédric
et et cédric et d'autre on me suis elle
aussi qui sont déjà en dix années au
pouvoir c'est aussi des syndicalistes
déjà engagés dans ce mouvement risi
croit savent à ce combat politique dont
qui pour eux ça fait partie de ceux de
cet ensemble et ils vont donc une
certaine cohérence dans leur
fonctionnement et leur combat nous celle
inverse exactement l'averse tout le
réseau des gens à qui on travaille sont
tous persuadés que l'on n'y croit plus
du tout à ce combat là et ça changera
pas les gens sont enfin pour plein de
raisons par contre on croit plus à
l'exemple la concrétude des actes
on attendait une société vieillissante
tout le monde le sait je moi je le redis
des fours gens aller sur internet et
vous cliquez pyramide des âges et puis
vous allez regarder c'est une pyramide
qu'on a nous sert vase à l'envers et
voilà il nous manque on n'a pas assez de
jeunes pour le sait après il ya des tas
d'études qui
qui atteste de ça il ya des chiffres on
parle de quelque chose de l'ordre de 50
millions de déficit de faire une force
de travail on ne reparle d'ici 2050 50
millions 350 me rends 150000 mire ans et
50 millions du coup on a besoin de ces
gens et nous tous les migrants qu'on
connaît avec qui on est resté en
relation et et qui ont eu le droit de
travailler enfin ils travaillent tous
tous des bouleaux pas toujours très bien
payé mais ils travaillent tous
photo
dallas
nous avons appris ce qu'est l'homme
et là je vais appeler l'allemagne alors
qu explique c'est une famille qui est
restée ici plusieurs mois ils sont
partis vivre en allemagne j'ai été les
voir il ya un nom et j'ai pas beaucoup
de nouvelles maintenant donc je me fais
du souci donc je leur demande comment
ils vont s'ils ont leurs papiers de
réfugiés où ils vivent et s'ils ont
besoin de quelque chose d'accord
à l'eau tiens tu sais moi de capelle en
amont françois du matin à
l'école
dans leurs papiers de réfugiés oui c'est
ça et la maison au nom de m à quelque
chose ce
label a pris d'avocat aussi
vite ou d enfanter de visiter
ma fiche moustiques baden et kehl
je vais revenir devoir d'avoir
manqué dans tes je te fais des gros gros
gros bisous à
bientôt
au revoir
moi j'ai pas eu l'impression de faire la
charité je dis franchement j'ai pas fait
la charité moi j'ai essayé de rétablir
un peu de justice j'ai essayé je le dis
je le répète
à l'âge que j'ai c'est un échec la
volonté que j'avais transformer le monde
j'ai échoué avec ma génération je dis on
a échoué pour des raisons diverses et
variées si on peut avoir l'impression
qu'on a un peu changé les choses à son
petit niveau sur la route de la roya je
trouve que c'est pas mal
je trouve ça complique et l'action
collective parce que tant que ces de
l'humanitaire on fait tous ensemble
ramassez ramasser des vivres ramasser
des vêtements les transporter bien sûr
qu'on fait tous ensemble mais ensuite
quand chacun veut en définitive essayé
de donner une vision fini de l'action et
d'en faire une action politique la halle
et rivages il recommence et moi j'ai pas
envie de me battre contre des clivages
dans cette action là
[Musique]
est-ce que je recommencerai ou est
certainement je recommencerai parce que
rien n'ait changé je recommencerai parce
que l'état est toujours aussi défaillant
je recommencerai parce que la misère
meurs tu toujours autant donc je
recommencerai
genlis et pour mettre entre otages et
dans les groupes seraient très beau
non
c'est très beau de mélanger des fuites
des fleurs aux légumes c'est poétique
oui
un fleuriste
sur lui il va faire sa vie mais ce sera
plus est chez lui ici moi je considère
qu'il est chez lui alors je vais pas
adopter c'est pas mon fils mais c'est
pas loin franchement c'est pas loin
j'aime beaucoup aujourd'hui
et demain je peux pas te dis c'est que
je voulais fait en fait
n'accepte de foire n'a pas trop de choix
en fait on saisit les opportunités
si les opportunités se présentent en
aval et je la saisis en fait
tu vois c'est un peu ça
[Musique]
le futur est incertain
on remarque souvent bien seul au
concours des call girls et or
c'est une ligne pourra mener quelques
pas
[Musique]
ah oui moi je veux bien rester en
contact avec l'humanité tu vois
je veux pas tu es en moi là c'est une
pratique mois
mais
[Musique]
quand ça
je veux bien rester en contact avec
l'humanité est resté uni jusqu'au
dernier joue
[Musique]
m